[Music]
this morning on the dish
food production for the people farmers
markets have proved to be invaluable
during the pandemic
by offering fresh food often in open air
environments
and in one state it's becoming even
easier to sell
homemade locally sourced food thanks to
a law passed five years ago
janet chamleon has the story
in jordan addison's gillette wyoming
kitchen the idea of getting government
off his back
all comes down to peanut butter
how he makes it add the salt and oil
how he packages it the particular
peanuts i'm using
ruff's about to about a pint and then
how he sells it
i'm operating under wyoming food freedom
act which allows me just to make it from
the house to the consumer
addison doesn't need his jars inspected
or weighed
and they're not subject to any
government oversight
he just delivers it to this co-op where
customers buy it directly
these would be eggs laid by a local hen
and her and her sisters did all this
yesterday
frank wallace is unofficially in charge
of gillette's farmer's co-op
almost everything here from the honey to
jordan addison's peanut butter
was made in someone's kitchen or on a
nearby farm
we have about 25 different local vendors
in there
some of them are pretty good sized and
some of them sell 10 or 15 dollars worth
of product a week
wyoming's food freedom law allows people
to sell directly to others without
regulation
from salsa to sauerkraut and pastries to
pickles
even meat though it's the one item that
must be processed in a licensed facility
right now we have nine beef at the
butcher
wallace says there hasn't been a single
case of illness tied to the local food
movement
since the law passed in 2015. we don't
have to
totally depend on the valley in
california where
if the rail car is contaminated then
thousands of people are sick if it gets
sick here
it's one or two people it hasn't
happened
lynn newsom is delivering goat's milk
which she says
helped in her husband's cancer recovery
it just told me on what goat's milk can
do and so i want to help other people
and i mean what better reason is there
than that
since wyoming's food freedom went into
effect north dakota
utah and maine have followed with
similar laws
other states have loosened restrictions
we're not putting the big box stores out
of business yet but
we're making a dent and people are
appreciating local foods
but what's made in wyoming has to stay
local
to keep the food and drug administration
out homemade food
can't be sold online
judy leggett both works in the co-op and
buys groceries here
we have less issues because there is
less chance of contamination because you
don't haul it for thousands of miles
you don't have 18 different companies
handling it so why are there food laws
in the first place
the food and drug administration was
sort of founded to ensure that
you know there was transparency from
that perspective and consumers
knew what was in the food product
is a professor and food safety expert at
the university of houston
there is an area of opportunity where we
can find some sort of middle ground
right where you sort of make it easy
sure for
vendors to be able to sell direct
consumer but you also
provide them resources um to do it in a
safe manner
at this tiny market in a city of 30 000
business is brisk across the country
demand for local food is surging
the number of farmers markets doubling
in the last decade
but food lobbies are doubling down
trying to make sure what's happening in
wyoming
doesn't spill across the border to
montana or other states
if i had my cow here we could milk it
out and get tell you something
40 miles north of here they're gonna
almost try to throw you in jail for
doing the same thing
for cbs this morning saturday i'm janet
shamley